drapé de bleu et de jaune des slogans à
la gloire du pays au cas où certains en
douteraient karkhiv et ukrainienne
la deuxième ville du pays dans l'est
majoritairement russophone veut envoyer
un message clair en ces temps troublés
la russie n'a pas d'alliés ici sur un
marché gris brûlures sur scène le
discours passe de la fierté nationale et
du patriotisme aux appels à se tenir
prêtes à défendre la ville
n'est pas nous ne paniquons pas nous
nous préparons gloire à la nation
celui qui chauffe la foule c'est
constantine n'imite chef c'est ultra
nationaliste dirige la cellule car qui
viennent du corps national une
organisation d'extrême droite
dure je crois que l'état ukrainienne en
fait pas assez surtout pas assez vite
pour préparer le pays à affronter la
menace de la russie voisine
malheureusement le gouvernement n'en
fait pas assez les gens ne savent pas où
trouver un abri ils ne savent pas quoi
faire ce qu'ils doivent prendre avec eux
il n'y a aucune information
alors nous assemblons sept défenseurs
civile pour protéger car qui joue et
nous tentons d'informer les gens
pourtant il ya moins de deux semaines le
président volodymyr elin ce qui a tourné
tous les projecteurs sur la ville de
kharkiv en déclarant en entrevue au
washington post que kharkiv pourrait
être occupé par la russie un choc
beaucoup ici ou président du losc quand
le président et dance qui a déclaré que
notre ville était une cible potentielle
les gens étaient certainement inquiet
mais étonnamment contrairement 2014 où
il était absolument tous perdu
impuissant
personne ne savait quoi faire et les
forces de l'ordre la police de l'armée
et du sbu étaient toutes en train de
s'effondrer maintenant karkhiv est dans
une situation complètement différente en
tant que boxeur qui s'est mise en forme
en 2014 des séparatistes pro russes ont
marché dans cette ville il au lourd
passé industriel brièvement ils ont
hissé le drapeau russe sur cet édifice
du gouvernement régional mais
contrairement aux villes de john yates
et de lougansk dans le dôme basse ils
ont été rapidement chassé de la ville
par les forces ukrainienne l'épisode a
marqué un véritable tournant pour
beaucoup ici
ils ont dû choisir leur camp êtes vous
une personne qui veut être un ukrainien
dans une crème unis où êtes vous une
personne qui veut qu luke haines cesse
d'exister
sevastianov à u2 réponse à cette crise
identitaire en 2014 d'abord il a pris
les armes pour défendre karkhiv ensuite
il a cessé de parler le russe sa langue
natale publiquement avant de nous
rencontrer le chanteur populaire on
avait plus accordé une seule entrevue en
russe s'il fait exception aujourd'hui
c'est pour faciliter la conversation
l'une des causes de la guerre pour la
principale mme c'était supposément la
protection de la population russophone
j'ai donc pensé que j'avais besoin de
m'éloigner un peu de cette tendance à
parler russe pour être plus en phase
avec l'ukraine je n'ai rien contre la
langue je la parle depuis ma naissance
mais je crois que c'est important pour
l'ukraine de soutenir la langue
ukrainienne
aujourd'hui c'est avec ces mots qui
combat les russes des mois serbe cru
sans être dépourvu d'une certaine ironie
tu perds au machrek chanson chachlyk en
réaction troupes massées tout près de la
frontière promet de faire des soldats
russes barbecue si d'aventuré il
revenait en ukraine
la guerre on ne veut pas trop y croire
et surtout en parler le moins possible
au marché de bar aba chauveau avec ses
75 hectares de petits commerces le long
d'aller entrecroisés il est l'un des
plus grands d'europe de l'est
yuliya devrait être au chaud chez elle à
la retraite dit elle mais elle n'a pas
les moyens de manger sans venir ici pour
vendre du thé et du café théâtre côté le
moma new york
doit tout l'étudier la question est
délicate nous avoue tania visiblement
bouleversé par l'idée d'une guerre comme
si tu attendais vraiment pas on ne sait
pas qu'il souhaite cette guerre
maintenant on ne sait pas comment c'est
possible j'ai de la famille là bas
comment je vais prendre les armes et les
tuer où ils vont venir ici pour me tuer
et puis quoi encore ça fait mal c'est
une telle douleur que quelqu'un qui
pense ça n'a aucun parent en russie
damien refuse de croire que c'est à la
russie d'assumer le rôle d'agresseur
d'ennemis de toute évidence la russie
fait partie d'elle elle coule dans ses
veines mais visiblement tout le monde
ici bien qu'ils soient d'origine russe
n'est pas du même avis
nicolas griche qu a été soldat dans
l'armée soviétique
jour au sein d'un régiment de
parachutistes en territoire ennemi sont
bien loin derrière lui mais il se dit
prêt à reprendre du service si
nécessaire je veux
ni
nikko
[Musique]
sera bientôt mort de toute façon dit il
philosophe
autant le faire de bout